what what is the naughtiest
kid you've ever faced over these years
naughtiest
well all children have a little bit of
naughtiness in them you know i always
children i ask will come up to me and
they'll say sam i've been naughty or am
i good
i'll say well i know that every child
has good days
and bad days okay the object is to have
more
good days than bad days so you you know
have a better
better level on the scale and everything
so uh
so all children i think deep down are
good you know
they get into a little mischief once in
a while you know
i kid around sometimes you know and
again depending on how old you are you
probably will get this joke but uh one
child could be creative two children get
very creative
three children together and one of them
turns into eddie haskell
or if not eddie haskell beetlejuice
the kids challenge each other and get
into mischief yes
very very common with that so now you
said you have children right
i do i have an eight-year-old a
seven-year-old and a three-year-old and
i can look i can go to that
seven-year-old
and and and say to the seven-year-old
you're not getting into your older
uh is it brother or sister brother two
older brothers
okay you're not getting into your older
brother's stuff are you
and that seven-year-old will sit there
sheepishly kind of like
yeah i do and the older one will say
yeah yeah he's always getting into my
stuff
you know and i can then look at the
eight-year-old and say
don't get mad your little brother is
just curious just
likes to look at your stuff i mean
you're curious too sometimes you sneak
in and look into daddy's stuff don't you
and the eight-year-old will probably get
big eyes and go
how did santa know classes
and classics so you know i looked at a
data a couple of statistics i pulled out
which i thought it was pretty
interesting
uh each christmas three billion
christmas cards are sent
in u.s alone okay another one is
according to data analyzed from facebook
post two weeks before christmas is one
of the two most popular times
for couples to break up however
christmas day is the least favorite day
for breakups
okay which i thought was pretty
interesting according to guinness book
of world records the tallest christmas
tree ever
cut was a 221 foot douglas fir
that was displayed in 1950 at the north
gate shopping center in seattle
washington
221 foot christmas tree that's a good
sized christmas tree
christmas trees have been sold in u.s
since 1850s
and you talked about the first time it
was called santa claus in a print was
coca-cola created the modern day muster
clause
and a department store santa's 120 year
old tradition
and the age where most kids
flip and they no longer believe in santa
is eight years old what is the oldest
person you met in your life that still
believe
believed in santa claus i i met
a lovely lady who was uh
102 at a
rest home a convalescent home uh it
actually was very surprised she still
walked around and everything and uh she
gave me a big and she believed oh yes
uh-huh she wanted to go on a date
[Laughter]
you know it's always fun
to meet people who believe you know
i've asked often you know why why is
this whole thing santa going on
you mentioned coca-cola in the 1930s
they
hate themselves illustration of santa
claus
and santa had been used in marketing and
advertising for many years
and so some people say well coca-cola
created the modern-day sale
well it evolved before that but the
reason santa exists and continues to
exist
is because of the parents and the
grandparents
and everything that they do for their
children and for others
you know this has been going on for 17
centuries
17 centuries since saint nicholas went
around
and and gave away his wealth to help
others and other people
followed in his habit his uh
custom of doing something for their kids
doing something for others
and it's because we seem to get an
enjoyment
doing something for others and we do it
for our children and we love doing it
and that feeling that we get is so good
we want to do it again so we repeat it
and
look what's happened yeah i bet
the feeling of giving is a priceless
feeling in christmas there's nothing
like it when everybody comes together
you're almost forced to do it you know
we like to do it period but christmas is
like
a mandatory time so for someone like you
are you married have you been married do
you have kids
yes i've been married almost 35 years we
have a
lovely daughter we have a one and a half
year old grandbaby
and they live near us here and
so i i get that enjoyment in fact we
just
the one child i got to hold for a
christmas photo
is my granddaughter you know and that's
you know the rest of the kids it's
it's all social distance you know
sometimes we have a sign
here's santa here's the family there's
six feet in between
and the sign says i'm six feet from
santa
this is as close as i'll get to the nice
list
that's fine you gotta find a way to get
creative so how is it being married to
santa or having a dad
data center or even a grandpa santa
well i don't think my granddaughter
knows yet what's going on she's only
a year and a half my daughter has
enjoyed it
uh i'm actually as part of my santa
school i've actually had
a dozen uh cruises we've gone on uh
princess cruises a dozen times with
anywhere from
20 to 40 couples all santas of mrs claus
and my daughter's gone with it so she's
experienced hanging around with the
santas and things like that
and uh so it it it's been very very
enjoyable
did you guys meet when you were dressed
as santa or no
oh well when you have a little beard
like this and uh
all the white hair to go with it why
uh of course the uh the thing is
is that uh you're santa year-round you
know 24 7 365.
and uh so sometimes you don't always
need the red suit
you know you can uh people will see this
cruddy mustache and they see this beard
i mean that's your real beard
[Laughter]
is that your real beard right you have
on that's yours that's not
uh no additions here no this is all real
you know that's what the little old
ladies like to pull on
[Music]